hila PETA in Samara from KTLA nice to
see you it's good to see you
we talked about this process first began
mm-hmm and now as you have gone through
it what has it been like it is it what
you expected it would be
I didn't expect anything no I there's no
way that I could have dreamt any of this
stuff up and it has been it's just been
an incredible journey and it continues
to be that it's an adventure and a very
exciting one a very rewarding one and a
very revealing one as well yeah Lucas I
know you were born in Mexico do you plan
to celebrate with the Kela do you feel
me Espinosa where no sé pero si tengo
myth make o make me encanta Sur mexicana
me gusta ser mexicana is parte de mie
Astoria and yes I I have a warm place in
my heart for Mexico as I do for my other
country as well Kenya
so yes IIIi have been celebrated in both
places in it and also in America and it
seems in many different parts of the
world and that is a humbling experience
you know to have so many people embrace
you and to have so many people identify
with you and that's the beauty of film
you know that it brings people closer
together
different evening this University
Korea nomination
Oh what do I think how I mean that's a
good question
I I mean it's a recognition of the
highest you know like everybody regards
the the Oscars as the ultimate stamp of
approval and I don't know I guess we'll
see
[Applause]